lo que tenemos aquí podemos verlo como
un estado de equilibrio a largo plazo
para un mercado de competencia perfecta
digamos que este es el mercado de
manzanas en una situación idealizada de
competencia perfecta en donde hay muchas
empresas productoras no diferenciadas
tienen la misma estructura de costos y
no hay barreras para entrar o salir del
lado izquierdo vemos el precio de
equilibrio establecido por la
intersección de las curvas de la oferta
y de la demanda este es el precio que
tienen que aceptar las empresas ya hemos
hablado de esto en otros vídeos lo que
va a definir el ingreso marginal no solo
para esta empresa sino para todas las
empresas del mercado ya hemos hablado en
otros vídeos acerca del hecho de que la
cantidad racional que la empresa quiere
producir se encuentra donde se
intersecta el ingreso marginal con el
costo marginal y también será el punto
donde se tiene ganancia económica cero
para esa cantidad la cantidad para la
empresa en donde el costo total promedio
es igual al ingreso marginal si el
ingreso marginal fuera mayor que el
costo total promedio en esa cantidad
entonces tendríamos nuevos participantes
en el mercado
porque hay una ganancia económica
positiva si el ingreso marginal fuera
menor que el costo total promedio en
esta cantidad entonces las empresas
tendrían pérdidas económicas y
tendríamos empresas saliendo del mercado
en cualquiera de esas situaciones nos
regresaría al estado de equilibrio que
se ve aquí ahora imaginemos que algo
impacta al mercado un nuevo artículo
dice que las manzanas que se producen en
este mercado son tremendamente buenas
para la salud alargan la vida les hacen
sentir más felices y tener más amigos lo
que hace que aumente la demanda de
manzanas y que tengamos una nueva curva
de demanda que luce así de prima en esta
situación que es lo que va a ocurrir
ahora hay un nuevo precio de equilibrio
y también una nueva cantidad de
equilibrio llamamos al nuevo precio p
prima y va a definir una nueva curva de
ingreso marginal para los participantes
de la industria que es img prima y ahora
de pronto la nueva cantidad razonable a
producir al menos para que produzca esta
empresa es q prima para esta empresa y
noten que para esa cantidad se tiene
ganancia económica porque
a una de esas unidades se obtiene este
ingreso y este costo promedio por unidad
es decir se obtiene en esta cantidad una
ganancia y lo multiplicamos por la
cantidad de unidades producidas toda
esta área va a ser la ganancia económica
que obtiene esta empresa y es muy
probable que todas las empresas en este
mercado de competencia perfecta van a
tener la misma ganancia porque tienen la
misma estructura de costos pero como
mencionamos antes cuando se tiene
ganancia económica positiva y debido a
que no hay barreras para entrar a largo
plazo entrarán más empresas porque hay
ganancia económica en vídeos anteriores
hablamos de una situación donde conforme
las empresas entran o salen del mercado
la estructura de costos de las empresas
individuales no cambia ahora imaginemos
por un momento que con todas las
empresas que están entrando al mercado
porque parece que hay ganancia económica
para todos los que están en el algunos
de los insumos por ejemplo el producir
manzanas que es lo que hacen estas
empresas comienza a incrementar su costo
antes hablamos de mercado de competencia
perfecta con costos constantes
ahora hablamos de mercado de competencia
perfecta con costos crecientes en esta
situación la estructura de costos de la
empresa y de todas las empresas del
mercado va a cambiar ya que conforme
entran más empresas se va a pagar más
por las semillas de manzana o quizá hay
que pagar más por pesticidas o por cera
o por la tierra de cultivo por lo que
ahora tendremos una curva de costos
marginales diferente quizá la curva de
costo marginal luce así esta es la curva
de costo marginal prima también tenemos
una nueva curva de costo total promedio
ctp prima que quizás se ve más o menos
así por lo que pueden imaginarse que las
empresas que se apresuraron a entrar al
mercado pensando que tendrían ganancia
económica pero sólo lo logran hasta que
la ganancia económica de todas las
empresas llega a cero en qué punto se
tiene ganancia económica cero es cuando
el ingreso marginal de la empresa es
igual al costo marginal y es igual al
costo total promedio es este punto de
acá llegamos a este punto de aquí que
llamamos ingreso marginal primo por lo
que nuevas empresas entrarán al mercado
hasta que el precio de equilibrio llegue
a la oferta va a incrementar por las
empresas que quieren tener ganancia
económica pero solo va a incrementar
hasta este punto se desplaza un poco a
la derecha hasta llegar a oprima como
pueden ver con base en esto podemos
imaginar la curva de la oferta a largo
plazo en este mercado de competencia
perfecta donde hay costos crecientes
estábamos por acá este era el punto de
equilibrio antes ahora estamos por acá
de manera que la curva de la oferta a
largo plazo en este ambiente donde hay
costos crecientes que es de competencia
perfecta puede lucir así en el mundo de
costos constantes esta era una recta
plana pero ahora en el mundo de costos
crecientes donde las empresas entran al
mercado pero se incrementa la estructura
de costos para producir una manzana la
curva de la oferta a largo plazo es esta
recuerden que el largo plazo es que
transcurre el tiempo suficiente para que
las empresas puedan entrar o salir del
mercado o que pasa el tiempo suficiente
para que los costos fijos ya no sean
fijos donde
pueden eliminar o se pueden incrementar
ahora podemos hacer otro ejercicio
mental digamos que tenemos un mercado
donde conforme entran nuevas empresas al
mercado disminuyen los costos de
producción y aunque sea difícil de creer
pueden imaginar que ahora las personas
pueden producir semillas o cera a una
nueva escala por lo que los insumos se
vuelven más baratos en este caso
veríamos lo opuesto veríamos que
conforme entran más empresas al mercado
disminuye la estructura de costos de
manera que la oferta aumenta cada vez
más hasta que el precio de equilibrio es
menor de lo que era antes ahora
tendríamos una curva de la oferta a
largo plazo con una pendiente negativa